ce vieux bob des années 50 au père comme
par magie et bruno maj on retrouve les
souvenirs de son enfance une passion du
bauhb hérité de son père et de son
grand-père qui utilisait la même machine
le bob dernière génération est nettement
plus sophistiqués plus aérodynamique
pour gagner du temps et s'offrir le
grand frisson une chose que chez
embarquez donc les deux mains sur le
pôle il fonctionne bien sur la poignée
droite pour la droite et la gauche pour
la gauche a tout simple donc j'oriente
mon bob là où j'ai décidé d'aller bruno
masson c'est l'homme qui glisse dans sa
tête pour préparer avec une extrême
concentration chaque descente en
bobsleigh cet équilibriste sur glace se
refait mentalement la descente pour
essayer de corriger ces défauts
améliorer sans cesse y trajectoire pour
aller toujours plus vite à plus de 130
kilomètres heure pour ses derniers jeux
le meilleur pilote français tentera avec
son tgv des glaces d'aller conquérir une
médaille olympique après le bronze de
nagano aujourd'hui on a un petit peu
plus éloignées en termes de potentiel
mais bon ça veut pas dire que ces jeux
ont ri rapport donc essayé but que ce
sera les derniers finir quelque chose en
beauté ces deux dernières années bruno
maj on a dû composer avec une nouvelle
génération de pousseur les résultats
n'ont guère été à la hauteur et le
patriarche du bob place du pilotage a
même perdu un peu de son talent naturel
et la totalité de ses cheveux à cause du
stress
d'où cette fierté retrouvée à l'idée de
porter le drapeau de la délégation
française
cette journée bar est vraiment
différente des autres journées où je
suis rentré c'est vraiment ça sera
peut-être pour moi mais cinquième jeu
mais seront différents puisqu'il y aura
un drapeau en main et je vais vraiment
essayer d'apprécier cette journée au
maximum
et après il sera alors temps pour lui de
passer le flambeau à son fiston ou un
autre jeune très prometteur
la relève est déjà là prête à prendre
tous les risques